[Music]
the babylon b is a satire site started
off pretty funny then it got
genuinely hilarious and incisive because
it persisted in telling the truth so of
course the new york times
hated that new york times recently
denounced the babylon bee as quote
a far far-right misinformation site that
quote sometimes traffics and
misinformation under the guise of satire
no humor allowed but the babylon b to
its
everlasting credit did not take that
sitting down they threatened to sue the
new york times for saying it
the times his lawyers wrote back
admitting that actually the new york
times can be a source of disinformation
which it certainly is
and then this quote we have removed the
reference to the babylon b from the
article
and appended a correction wow
seth dillon is the man who made that
happen who backed down the new york
times he's the ceo of the babylon b and
we are honored to have him join us
tonight
seth thanks so much for coming on i
don't know what happened to your site
how it got so great
it was good but then it got like amazing
um
but i didn't realize that you were the
huevos
to go after the new york times like good
for you why'd you do this
well first thank you for having me on
your show and give me a platform
from which to misinform your millions of
viewers uh harmfully
and maliciously uh i really appreciate
it sincerely
at any time that's what we do you know i
we can't take this stuff laying down we
actually as satirists we want to joke
about this stuff we want to just poke
fun at the new york times
the problem is like it or not the new
york times is considered a reliable
source
so you know when when the social
networks are looking to
decide who's satire who's misinformation
who's fake news
right you know they look to the new york
times they look to snopes they look to
cnn
uh and so when they're making these
mischaracterizations about us we have to
take it seriously
and we've got to come on even though we
don't want to we want to keep things
light
we got to send demand letters we got to
threaten to sue because otherwise we're
gonna get mischaracterized and we're
gonna get the boot from social media
oh so it's not just a question of honor
this is not just a duel because they
insulted you
this is a direct threat to your
existence to your business model
is what you're saying yeah absolutely
yeah i mean we
so we depend on the social networks for
traffic to our site if we lose the
social networks we lose our business
so uh it's really a self-preservation
thing absolutely it's about survival
how interesting i was i misread this
completely so that this is even more
sinister so the new york times by
calling you
a disinformation site is in in effect
threatening to shut you down
yeah and i i think that's a deliberate
strategy i mean look the
fake news has been a concern uh for
social networks for the last several
years
they've been trying to find ways to fact
check deep platform
and uh demonetize and de-boost people
who are spreading fake news on their
platforms
um and so you know the the legacy media
leftist media is taking advantage of
that
you know in that last segment you're
talking about comedy and how comedians
need to be leading the way
we're one of the few comedians who are
leading the way we're not we're not
trailing this we're out ahead of it
uh we're making fun of the things that
need to be made fun of we're ridiculing
bad ideas
um they have you know the new york times
has incredible disdain for us
i would guess uh by the way they're
treating us and the way they're handling
this because they know better
on the one hand it's extremely ironic
that they're using misinformation to
smear us as being a source
of it but beyond that it's comically
ironic
but beyond that it's malicious because
they know better
so really quick did you guys ever start
a war and say a rock under false
pretenses
over at the babylon b did we start what
under a war in iraq under false priests
yeah oh sorry that was the new york
times the new york times did yeah yeah
okay
you just want to check so when you guys
do that then i guess we'll criticize you
in the meantime congratulations on
running the funniest site on the
internet it's amazing
so thank you thank you hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else